Уже чотири мільйони українців втекли від війни за кордон.
Поліція і правозахисники побоюються, що такий масштабний приплив біженців
може призвести до сплеску злочинності у сфері торгівлі людьми, примусової праці й надання сексуальних послуг.
Берлінська благодійна організація IN VIA допомагає жінкам, які постраждали
від примусу до проституції  або від примусової праці.
Для українських біженців підготували інформаційні флаєри.
На жаль, реальність така, що, певно, знайдеться якийсь зловмисник, який захоче і спробує
отримати зиск на біді інших.
Зараз з України до Німеччини прибуває дуже багато людей,
їм надають величезну допомогу.
Але серед багатьох сумлінних помічників можуть опинитися люди,
які спробують скористатися ситуацією. А ми не хочемо, щоб біженці втрапили у халепу в Німеччині.
А від влади ми чекаємо,що вона надасть житло, транспорт...
Адже що краще налагоджено інфраструктуру, то менше у ній прогалин,
які зловмисники можуть використати для експлуатації людей.
Приміром, у перші тижні в Берліні виникла ситуація, що всім займалися волонтери.
І ніхто не знав, кого і куди відвезли та розмістили, хто пропонував транспорт та проживання.
Це саме ті ситуації, які можуть використати зловмисники.
2020 року Єврокомісія оцінювала річний обіг нелегального бізнесу з торгівлі людьми
та сексуальної експлуатації у цілому по ЄС - майже у 30 мільйонів євро.
Правозахисники Amnesty International, вивчивши ситуацію з біженцями в Польщі,
закликали владу посилити захист біженців від криміналу.
Ми бачили, як, наприклад, якась жінка пропонувала гроші людям, які прибули потягом з України.
І казала, що дасть гроші на паспорти. А це, звичайно, означає, що у людей
забирають посвідчення особи - і заразом усі права у майбутньому.
При цьому жодної правової підстави для подібних дій, звісно, ​​немає.
Або випадок у місті Вроцлав. Там поліція провадить слідство за фактом зґвалтування
громадянином Польщі жінки з України. Потрібно пам'ятати, що багато подібних випадків
стається у тіні й їх майже неможливо розслідувати.
Німецька поліція упродовж 2020-го розслідувала 465 справ щодо торгівлі людьми,
понад половина постраждалих зазнавала сексуальних домагань. Більшість жертв - зі Східної Європи.
Їх примушують до нелегальної роботи прибиральницями й доглядальницями,
зарплата - значно менша від установлених законом норм.
Берлінські активісти зібрали докупи рекомендації для біженок з України -
листівки з номерами телефонів гарячої лінії роздають не лише в самому Берліні, а й на околицях.
Нікому не віддавайте свій паспорт. Ідіть геть з квартир, які видаються вам небезпечними.
Звертайтеся до консультаційних пунктів, якщо потрібна допомога.
А в критичній ситуації дзвоніть у поліцію.
Водночас із поліцейських кіл лунає інша рекомендація - не панікувати й не перебільшувати.
Співробітники федеральної поліції вже звернули увагу на підозрілих осіб та провели бесіди з ними.
Але водночас слід розуміти, що якщо хтось обертається у сутенерських колах й опиняється
на центральному вокзалі Берліна, поліція у будь-якому разі зверне на нього увагу.
Щоправда, це зовсім не означає, що там процвітає торгівля людьми…
Поліція вживає відповідних заходів на місцях. Водночас слід бути обережнішими, щоб не сіяти паніку.
Торгівля людьми - галузь організованої злочинності, де можна заробити великі гроші.
І де експлуатують потреби інших людей. Окрім соціальної нерівності - люди у Західній Європі
заробляють більше, ніж у Східній - війна слугує додатковим стимулом. Люди змушені тікати
з небезпечних місць туди, де кращі перспективи життя. Однак коли - через великий потік біженців і бюрократію -
люди не можуть швидко облаштуватися на новому місці, ризик стати жертвою злочинців для них підвищується.
Експерти Amnesty International рекомендують звертатися до них за найменшої підозри
щодо намірів людей, які пропонують допомогу.
Звісно, усі хотіли би, щоб певні заходи було вжито набагато раніше.
Зокрема і з боку держструктур, приміром Берлінського сенату.
Наприклад, щоби приватні особи не приїздили на вокзал і не пропонували там приватне розміщення,
а натомість співпрацювали з місцевою онлайн-платформою з пошуку житла для біженців.
Це набагато розумніше й дозволяє здійснювати контроль на іншому рівні.
Подібні заходи зрештою таки вжили, але доволі пізно. Звичайно, Берлін залишається
таким собі голковим вушком на шляху з Польщі до Німеччини,  а розподіл біженців Німеччиною
на початку теж буксував. Та й ситуація із житлом дуже непроста.
Захисники прав жінок закликають владу посилити захист біженців, а самих біженців бути обережнішими
і перевіряти надто спокусливі пропозиції щодо роботи чи житла.